all right Ronnie is with us Ronnie's in
Baton Rouge Louisiana hi Ronnie welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Dave thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up well I need a little
guidance I guess on how to handle a
situation I've got going on with my
mother her finances she is 74 years old
she is a widower and she lives in a
little retirement community a little um
you know for the elderly but she doesn't
pay too bad in rent now she brings in
roughly $2,000 a month and that you know
if she would that's enough for her to
live you know within our means she
doesn't own anything but her problem is
is that she is spending too much money
on I guess things that she wants and
wants to do rather than staying on a
budget and it's getting her in trouble
and she ends up going through these
payday loan places and I bailed her out
once before on it and I sat down work
budget out with her and now she's called
me again and she's eight hundred dollars
in debt to him again what is her known
what is your household income uh between
my wife and I were at eighty thousand
okay so when you sit down and say mom
why didn't you stick to the budget why
did you go to the stupid payday lender
why did you go to these loan sharks what
does she say because she has to know
that's stupid
yes and and well what I get is is she
tries to like this last time she told me
whether reason I got messed up is I had
to pay for this stuff for my eye surgery
I'm like you know um that's that's not
the case you know so she she doesn't
really say you know it's my fault I'm
doing this but I've talked to my I have
an older sister that she's not able to
help either but and found out that my
mother is buying stuff off of the TVs I
guess through QVC in places like that
and your splurging when she doesn't need
to be splurging and she waits til it
gets to this point before she last
we have not asked her before you know
when you get into situation you need
some help you know with doctor visits or
groceries or whatever call me and I
never get a phone call until it's hey
they're telling me they're going to turn
me over to the VA if I don't pay this
$800 yeah and I guess I feel obligated
because she's my mother but well you're
not you're not obligated to finance
someone's cocaine use this is
misbehavior it's not cocaine use but
it's misbehavior and the fact that
someone is your mother does not obligate
you to finance their misbehavior she's
out of control and when you finance her
misbehavior counselors call that
enabling meaning that you're causing her
to misbehave because you're
participating in the madness so
something's got to stop now I don't
think it needs to be you just call her
up and go no mom I'm not giving you any
money I don't like you anymore and I
think you're crazy
I wouldn't do that I'm not suggesting
that at all but I think you are going to
have to really forcefully insert
yourself in this situation explaining
that we are not going to do this any
more and if you ever come to me for
money again ever
because you've mismanaged and haven't
handled this and I'm going to be helping
you with your budget every month but if
you misbehaving you don't stick to what
we've discussed then I'm just going to
have to the only way I'm going to be
able give you money in the future is I'm
gonna have to take over all your
financial affairs and I'll have to
manage your money for you and I won't
give you money to buy stuff on QVC
okay and so because I'm a mom I'm not
going to participate in you misbehaving
I agree 100% that's not an act of love
the next problem that I have now though
is at this particular time I don't have
the money to be able to do this and I
would have to borrow this money
well I wouldn't borrow it I would just
call up the guy to say you're not
getting paid because you loaned a
seventy-year-old broke person on two
thousand dollars a month
money as a payday lender well we're
going to call the DA fine column because
guess what they cannot fit
or they cannot criminally prosecute as
payday lenders the very business model
of a payday lender is to ask you to
write a hot check so they can't turn
around then and prosecute on a hot check
okay so that's a complete bluff that's
what I did speak to them and that was
another date their answer was we'll hold
it to January the third but after that
we got to have money or we want to turn
it over to be a fine turn over the DA
okay do it because you guys are full of
crap you're scum you're bottom feeders
and you're not going to turn it over to
the DA if you do I'm going to put you on
the front page of the newspaper for
prosecuting a 70 year old woman that's a
widow that you've taken advantage of I'm
going to wear you out so have at it
please turn it over the DA we're going
to turn you into a PR disaster but in
the meantime your mother has to stay out
of those freakin places yes she does I
mean I'm going to be nice but I'm going
to be very firm with her if I'm you and
that's being loving by the way it's not
being disrespectful it's mom you're
doing cocaine you have to stop it payday
lenders are financial cocaine it's crack
you follow me yes sir and that's how
she's acted it's like she's doing crack
but with her checkbook it's just crazy
crazy crazy it has to stop and so when
you jack it up that way we've got to get
all up in mom's business further than
just throwing some money over there
occasionally we got to say okay here's
the freaking budget and you're and I'm
going to check with you every week and
ask you about this budget and did she
live in your town yes good you could
just ride your little butt over there
and sit down her kitchen table and check
our budget with her once a month once a
week or once a month or twice a month or
whatever you got to do right right
you're just going to have to hold her
hand because she's not capable for some
reason or another and this is going to
keep coming up we're treating the
symptom we're not treating the problem
thanks for the call